excuse me no he's not camera in the
store no out so you want to cover story
so you need the camera outside it's
enough okay I'm in the store can you
just ask you a few questions
no question out get ice in my store okay
okay daddy oh I'm sorry we'll clean that
up sir
come yes are you David so I use the
YouTube celebrity David so can I ask you
can you get in there you do the asking
because I'm tired of you mother coming
up in my god there's going get the joke
get the scout it is shoot at us
apple just shot us
so what you guys want um has been
harassing me let me know
I decided to run my parents business I
run my store a little bit differently
than I did with my parents okay
see they were into this whole idea of
being nice to your customers having a
good customer service I don't believe in
it the accent is a way for me to watch
the customers you know English they'll
run all over you you have to speak in an
accent to make sure that they know that
they're thieves so you wouldn't
understand this because you grew up in a
nice area see I grew up decrepit my
parents believed in something they
called customer service to run your
business I don't believe in that mess I
believe in enforcement meet my best
friend
chitty-chitty bang-bang thank you
[ __ ] my parents also had this other
rule don't hire black people but why not
black people understand black people the
best you should meet my friend
Icom like chocolate like chocolate run
the store with me
you see I'm saying he understands how
people still because he is in the mind
what does that mean you wouldn't
understand you hi what can the Kings be
surprised um thanks a lot
sorry sir you need to help anything um
I'm cool right now I'm just looking
around out a few things I got a pickup
well c'mon I need help you see you let
me know okay sure without a doubt okay
you know Toberman Zeki
one very good go yeah not potential he's
like to my little rich girl I get food
Nita I trained him I've trained him well
okay I told him that in order to be a
good customer service associate you have
to watch him like a hawk
don't give them any breathing make sure
that you breathing down the neck because
if you don't they'll just run all over
you
if he squats you squat he breathes you
breathe he stops blinking you keep your
eyes open to exactly how you wanted
cuz I'm black I'm black too sir
you dis you bye you see I don't just
train my employees to catch people steal
you see I'm a multicultural much watch
this
je introduce yourself Han Yeo concern
you annyeonghaseyo [ __ ] here's another
rule for you
teaching employees to not speak English
correctly
Jai has a perfect Korean accent je work
it you this u by UD see you bye
[ __ ]
I am I see you J Anita see my sake
money is interesting it can change a man
I'm not saying that I bought a lot of
ridiculous things but I did okay uh for
example let me ask you what's your mayor
it's cotton cotton right guess what my
shirts were made out of just guess
100% Japanese dolphin have you ever
heard of that no you haven't
I only had one let me ask you something
else what are these shoes made out of
that's giraffe
I mean what's a typical Miller people
would eat sandwiches hot dogs hamburgers
if you want to be a little fancy you go
get some Italian food some pasta guess
what I have your head dolphin says she
me before it's delicious
hey depends here we had a little bit of
argument about it she always be
screaming in my face don't kill the
dolphins don't kill the dolphins I have
money I can kill dolphins if I want to
do you know what it's like to ride a
rhino you don't do you I had six rhinos
17 giraffes three lions two Tigers I've
read them all together created my own
creature do you know what it's like to
own a unicorn but you don't I had one I
had a unicorn I called a dolly dolly
parton things in my world were a little
bit different you know I mean like a lot
of people they would you guys have
refrigerators to keep yourself cool
right well so what's the icemaker to you
you go to a machine press the button ice
comes out guess what my max ranking was
made out of there was a Mexican
immigrant named Jose lived in my closet
had a bucket ice I think he's still
there
you know what a dragon is I don't
believe three dragons now I'm not
talking about a little lizard I'll tell
him an actual dragon used to play with
my unicorn
a lot of my friends got a little bit fed
up with things that I was doing last I
saw him he was he's saying something
about like David's art taking a bunch of
animals like unicorns and mythological
creatures and creating something I would
kind of throw my money in their face
sometimes um you know I'm not so much
you know if they would ask for a ride
you know I'll come in and bring in my
plane still the women and children you
know it's just basic stuff don't act
like you've never done it before you
know we've never done that shut up
roughly around 2015 I had a sex scandal
not so much that I had sex with somebody
I try to create my own people didn't
believe it so the rumor of the cess
scandal um David try to make one with a
bunch of celebrities but it never
happened people didn't buy it they
didn't buy it it he would give them
money like look this happened he would
show them tapes this happened and her
goes like no that's cgi-animated so I
heard you're a virgin
what what is a virgin anyways okay if
you touch yourself at night does that
still mean you're virgin I'm not a
virgin you're virgin hey let's face it
you're virgin okay you know what call me
a virgin one more time okay yours let
there we go have you ever crossed animal
DNA with human DNA
have I ever crossed an animal with a
human yeah the wall were Potamus it is a
walrus and a hippopotamus mixed together
and I spliced in a little bit of Rosie
O'Donnell's genes in it thing was huge
I had a great white shark hat messed
with the dolphin suit Rhino shoes bald
eagle sure have you ever had roast bald
eagle they're quite delicious roast
dolphin sashimi giraffe have you ever
spanked the line before no yeah of
course you when you're broke broke
people can't do [ __ ] like that that's
how rich I was
you know after a while years went by and
I started dating a lot of celebrities
when they became of age Selena Gomez
when she became legal I went after her
dad the real quick BAM
Justin be back to handy turned lesbian
anyways didn't really matter Miley Cyrus
had a teeth fixed no I've never really
understood that you know that was like
probably our biggest problem over
together she was a celebrity but she
couldn't get braces look at mouthful
antlers I became a really big craze in
Japan I was sponsored by Hello Kitty
keroppi maybe you remember Keroppi
Pokemon sponsored me they put me in
front of a pokeball gotta catch them all
so can you tell me what does the future
of David so hold this is it for me
um I've lived a life you know me I'm
roughly about 52 now okay you look great
I know I do I am done you know I live
the life I live the Hollywood lifestyle
I had sex with all the ladies sometimes
a man which would go in alleged sex it's
not alleged you your [ __ ] exactly
you